[Música]
bom dia é hoje vou falar eu já hoje eu
trouxe uma tirinha que fala muito bem
sobre o tema é uma pessoa não um
espantalho certeza como você sabe não
está olhando no celular é mesmo essa
tinha mostra que bom até os corpos já
perceberam que a gente está usando seu
lado demais e pelo menos eu acho isso um
problema
o problema é que o celular é muito útil
e muito atraente para todas as idades e
acaba causando transtornos familiares
emocionais e até escolas
a gente precisa resolver isso
como a gente pode fazer isso a gente
precisa diminuir o tempo do uso dos
aplicativos eng
eu trouxe alguns aplicativos que nos
ajudou a fazer isso
o flor este que cresce e cresce um marco
no seu celular enquanto você não está
usando o flip que tranca solar projeto
tempo youtube kits que é para as
crianças menores que querem ver o
youtube os pais querem ter um maior
controle e eu tenho podido sobre o iof
que você consegue ver com o tempo seja o
indicado de cada aplicativo e restringe
tempo entre outros
mas o que falta
o que falta é que todos os aplicativos
se preocupam só com o tempo e não com o
que a pessoa tá vendo por exemplo alguém
vê 30 minutos e dexter considerado de
forma diferente de alguém que vem
teremos uma série de tv por exemplo
alguém que está fazendo uma pesquisa da
escola de alguém que está jogando o jogo
e tive uma idéia uma idéia tão
aplicativo the field feitas pela
internet e etc algumas etapas no caso
três
a primeira seria a autoclassificação que
o próprio autor do conteúdo é ter aqui
duas classificações
a primeira seria o tipo de estudos é
para diversão sem informativo eo segundo
será a classificação etária de 7 a 10
anos sempre há 12 anos que aparece nos
filmes e séries de tv
a segunda etapa seria automação seria
uma ferramenta para chegar
a etapa anterior o melhor que o outro
colocou a terceira e última etapa seria
a certificação humana seria mais ou
menos as primeiras 200 pessoas que virem
aquele conteúdo certificarem ou não se
aquilo ali pra elas tá certo
ou é esse aplicativo teve alguns
benefícios entre eles o mais importante
é que você conseguiria restringe tempo
não do aplicativo em geral mas sim
dependendo de cada tipo por exemplo
tanto tempo informativo tanto tempo de
diversão tanto tempo de estudo
dependendo do dia da semana ou do que
você quer está disposto a declarar seu
celular
leia com atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]